afghanistan's acting foreign minister is
leading a taliban delegation that has
met with eu representatives in doha the
eu says that it's still not recognizing
the taliban government but wants to keep
communication channels open let's go
live now to al jazeera's osama bin javid
who joins us now live from doha
what was the mood like around these
talks osama
well this is not the first time they've
met representatives from the european
union and this was a special
representative from the european union
and eu agencies meeting the de facto
government in afghanistan which calls
itself the islamic emirate of
afghanistan it is an urgent mission on
the agenda of the foreign minister who
says that he is in doha to speak to all
sides and talk to them not just about
the pressing issues inside afghanistan
but about the very important issue of
afghan funds which the united states has
decided that it will be using for other
purposes then returning to afghanistan
and that is something that the afghan
government in charge says is illegal to
discuss that and all the other meetings
they've been having here in the qatari
capital doha with us is the chief of the
political office in doha and the nominee
for the united nations mr soil shaheen
thank you very much for joining us uh
you've been meeting gcc representatives
in the last 24 hours you've also met eu
representatives what are you trying to
get out of this as the eu says that this
is not going to be a recognition of the
government in charge in afghanistan
afghanistan is under our control there
is no
place
where we do not have control we have
control all over the country the people
of afghanistan support us
uh it was the support of the people of
afghanistan that we fought for 20 years
in order to
to liberate our country
that is the government of the people of
afghanistan the sanctions imposed on the
people of afghanistan
by usa in the international community
are
punishing the people of afghanistan the
humanitarian crisis created now and the
people of afghanistan are passing
through is because of those sanctions
but there are a lot of demands from
various international partners uh
saying that the afghan authorities are
not delivering on promises on human
rights on women's rights on girls
education and various aspects of civil
liberties of afghan society how have you
assured them that it is on your agenda
and they should
believe your words
these are only claims
see the other day the minister of higher
education who is also here
in dauha and he participated in the
meeting today
he announced
that public universities and private
universities they are all open for male
and female students
he told me the other day that he have
about
100
120 000
administrative female workers lecturers
professors and female students all over
afghanistan these are the realities but
the word doesn't know about this but
what about the journalists who are being
picked up we saw a humanitarian worker
with the unhcr being picked up some
rights activists were abducted who have
been released so is the situation really
under the control of the government and
are you delivering on these promises of
equal rights for every afghan
if you do not have passport invasions
here where i am standing in dawah the
police has right to ask you so this is
the case there are some
legal cases there and when so they are
detained for that and there is some
suspicion and they are released when
they provide the proof let's talk about
these meetings that you're having as far
as we know that the most important point
on your agenda is the release of funds
that are being held in various european
capitals and the united states have you
been given any assurances is there going
to be a reversal of the decision are you
pressing on gcc countries including
qatar to talk to the united states or
are you going to be talking to the us
directly we are talking to all countries
we want the reversal of this decision
these many are the property of the
people of afghanistan it is the reserve
of the afghanistan bank
the afghanistan bank uses this reserve
for trade
for its monetary policy
and also for keeping the current the
abraham currency stable
otherwise it could not do that
so
that would lead to hitting the people
the punishing the people of afghanistan
if that happens and finally the
humanitarian situation in afghanistan as
we've seen has been deteriorating for
the last few months it is pretty bad
people have not been paid there is dire
poverty on the streets in various areas
of afghanistan what is the current
government doing to alleviate the
suffering of the afghan people and what
assurances have you been given by the
international community we have
given salaries to employees of different
ministries
for the past months
and that has been done from our internal
revenues
though it has made it for us difficult
the sanction which has been imposed by
the international community community on
the people of afghanistan and
afghanistan
but we are doing what we can for our
people
and we are talking to all
sides to all countries that it is
injustice the sanctions
hitting the people of afghanistan
and
you know our business men are not able
to send their money
you know for many commercial purposes
there is no
inflow in outlook or money which is
needed
for keeping the value of the currency of
one currency stable so
this is the demand of the people of
afghanistan that this sanction should be
removed thank you mr shaheen that was
soheil shaheen the
man in charge of the political office
here in the qatari capital doha and the
nominee for the united nations from the
de facto government in afghanistan they
are going to be continuing these
meetings it is an array of meetings a
high-level delegation which is going to
be meeting people uh from the qatari
side about the airport in kabul to
resume uh chartered flights from there
uh there's also going to be discussions
about humanitarian aid and there's some
sort of resolution to the political
status of the current government in
afghanistan which the taliban wanted uh
to be removed the sanctions to be lifted
and them to be recognized by the
international community including those
european leaders who've met the taliban
today saying that this is not a
recognition of the government but merely
a opening of a door where the people who
are in charge of afghanistan should be
dealt with should be negotiated with and
some sort of solution
needs to be found for the millions of
people in afghanistan suffering from the
current political and economic situation
al jazeera's osama bin laden reporting
live there from doha many thanks osama